Podcast-Ufo, wär doch glatt gelacht, weisst du, wer uns jede Woche glücklich macht?
Podcast-Ufo, ich sag's jederzeit, Samstagmittag, ich bin bereit. Wahnsinn, vielen, vielen Dank für das tolle Intro. Mega, mega gut, vielen Dank Richard für dieses fantastische Intro und diese herrliche, kratzige, raue Stimme. Ich frage mich bei solchen Sachen immer, wacht man extra früh auf und fliegt direkt ins Tonstudio nach London, wo man sagt, ja bin gerade aufgewacht, ich habe gerade so eine kratzige Stimme, jetzt mache ich Orgenroll. Wir müssen jetzt den Termin machen und alle sagen, nee, das Studio können wir nicht so früh vorziehen. Nein, schmeißt diesen Rapper raus, schmeißt den Rapper raus, ich habe eine Klampfe dabei, mehr brauchen wir nicht. Nein, das geht nicht. Wieso denn? Ja, gut. Okay, bis morgen. Das Fenster ist zu. Aber hast du das damals auch so gemacht, als es darum ging, die Handy-Mailbox zu besprechen? Ich habe immer gewartet auf den Moment, wo ich eine kratzige, so eine richtig raue, kratzige, herbe Männerstimme habe, um dann einzusprechen, hallo, das ist die Mailbox von Florentin Will, hinterlass deine Nachricht. Die alle, die das eingewerden, denken sich, wer ist das, wo bin ich hier? Du musst auch sagen, dass du damals mit 14 halt sonst eigentlich so gesprochen hast, ein bisschen höher. Ne, ich habe immer darauf gewartet, bis es möglichst laut im Hintergrund war, viel Blaulicht, Hupen, Wind, wahnsinnig viele Leute, die sprechen, damit man so denkt, oh krass, der hat so wenig, der hat so viel zu tun in seinem Leben, so ein beschäftigter Mann, dass er selbst keine Zeit hat, diese Sache irgendwo aufzunehmen, wo es ruhig ist, wow, der ist ein Jet-Setter, der ist unterwegs.
Absolut, der hat nicht mal zehn Sekunden Ruhe in seinem Leben, wo man es in Ruhe macht, der muss es auf dem Weg zum Flughafen machen. Der macht es auf dem Weg, on the fly. Das ist auch immer so perfid, wenn Leute fragen, hast du Zeit für eine Minute Call die Woche und man sagt, nee. Du wirst erleben, wo du eine ganze Woche lang nicht eine Minute Call die Woche und man sagt, nee.
Du wirst erleben, wo du eine ganze Woche lang nicht eine Minute Zeit hast,
nee, leider, ich bin komplett voll.
Komplett so, ich meine, Talent ist so voll.
Das ist ein Problem bei mir, ehrlich gesagt, weil ich oft fahre mit, ist so voll alles, beim Talent ist so voll, aber je kürzer die Termine werden,
desto schwieriger ist diese Ausrede anzubringen.
Und dann bin ich mittlerweile bei so esoterischem Kram wie,
nee, habe ich keinen Kopf für und sowas. Das geht dann aber auch nicht so gut. Da mag ich mich selber nicht in der Mail. Aber dieses Intro kam nicht alleine. Nein. Es kam in einer fantastischen lieben Nachricht von dem Richard. Und Flotti liest die jetzt mal vor. Genau, Richard ist nämlich Musikwissenschaftler und plant ein neues Projekt. Er schreibt, ich bringe übrigens ein Bob Dylan Magazin raus. Und da muss man sagen, das hat man gehört.
Ja, das kam durch. Und falls einer von euch
jemanden kennt, der Interesse hat,
irgendwie einen Text zu seinem
Verhältnis zu Bob Dylan zu schreiben,
kommt gerne auf mich zu. Jetzt
kenne ich drei Leute, Aurel Merz und Lars
Paulsen und Etienne Gade.
Kein Bob Dylan Aficionado
unter meinen Freunden. Weiss man nicht.
Ich glaube, heutzutage laufen Bob Dylan Aficionados nicht mehr mit Bob Dylan-Afficionado unter meinen Freunden. Weiss man nicht. Ich glaube, heutzutage laufen Bob Dylan-Afficionados nicht mehr mit Bob Dylan-Shirts herum. Ja, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, ich weiß nicht hundertprozentig, wer Bob Dylan ist, ist es der, der von Tilders Winton gespielt wurde in dem Film? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube schon. Hilft aber nicht einzugrenzen, weil alle wurden schon mal von Tilders Winton gespielt. Gut, das stimmt. Nee, darum geht's ... Der hat eine Mini-Mini-Rolle, also nicht er, aber sein ... sein ... sein Schaffen ... Oeuvre. Sein Oeuvre wird kurz angesprochen in Inside Llewyn Davis, einer meiner absoluten Lieblingsfilme, weil da am Ende singt er ja dann. Bob Dylan hat den Literatur-Nobelpreis gewonnen. Nach wie vor ein bisschen ... Für dieses Booklet bei der CD, oder was? Genau, er hat dann so die Danksagungen in der CD. Danke an Beata, Britta und Bobby. Vielen Dank an London Studios, vielen, vielen Dank an Britta. Limited. Der hat für seine Texte, aber es ist nach wie vor so ein bisschen, wird es belacht, belächelt, behustet, weil man sich fragt, warum er jetzt genau, weil er ja nur Songtexte geschrieben hat. Und ist das der einzige Musiker, der für Lieder den Literaturnobelpreis gewonnen hat? Gute Frage, kann ich nicht beantworten. Gut, alles klar. Fun Fact, Freud hat auch den Literaturnobelpreis gewonnen. Fun Fact, Richard macht kein Magazin über Freud. Gut, ja, da könnte ich natürlich euch vermitteln. Kennst du Leute, die Bob Dylan-Fans sind oder ein besonderes Verhältnis zu Bob Dylan haben, die immer am Flughafen kontrolliert haben oder die am McDrivebeitet haben. Und eines Tages hat man schon so Gitarre in der Ferne gehört und man dachte, oh, das geht aber direkt ans Herz. Ich habe selber eine Bob-Dilling-Geschichte, aber die würde dir sehr privat, die erzähle ich mal irgendwann in Folge 500 oder so. Oder du kannst sie ja einreichen in dem Magazin von Richard. Also, falls ihr jemanden kennt oder jemand seid, der ein besonderes Verhältnis zu Bob Dylan hat und oder einen cleveren Essay-Text schreiben könnte, klassisches Magazinfutter, sagen wir mal so. Oder sagen wir mal, wenn ihr Werbung in einem Bob Dylan-Magazin schalten wollt, weil ihr irgendwie der größte Bob Dylan-Fanshop in Stuttgart-West habt, dann würde ich sagen, schreibt den mal. Er schreibt uns, wir können das weitervermitteln an Richard, dann kommt da vielleicht was zustande. Jetzt kommt aber eine Welle an Bob Dylan-artig Anfrage. Ehrlich gesagt, glaube ich nicht. Glaubst du, wir kriegen jetzt 200 Bob Dylan-Essays rein? Ich glaube, unser Postfach war noch nicht so voll, ehrlich gesagt. Aber jetzt mal ein blöder Tipp, Richard, mach doch einen Podcast. Jetzt ist Bob Dylan halt so Special Interest, ja, nichts gegen Bob Dylan, aber ich glaube nicht, dass dass jetzt Magazine, auch Magazine sind ja auch schon Special Interest. Aber damit sind wirklich diese Papiermagazine gemeint, oder was? Es sind die Druckerzeugnisse gemeint, wie man das früher kennt, so von Guttenberg, der die ersten Magazine gedruckt hat. Ach du meine Güte. Aber ja, es stimmt schon, aber sind nicht Musiker auch sehr magazinaffin? Ich denke da an die Rockstar, die Popstar, die Rolling Stone. Sind nicht Magazine noch die Letzten, die noch Magazine lesen überhaupt, ausser Donald Duck-Fans? Ja, und Leute, Fans, Kultur interessiert vom New Yorker. Ja, das stimmt. Wobei das ist auch wirklich, das ist wie so ein Kunstwerk, was man kauft. Immer mit diesen schönen Covern und so. Das ist das einzige Magazin, was ich dann,
aber auch da ist mir immer schon ein bisschen peinlich,
in so einen Laden zu gehen und zu sagen, habt ihr den New Yorker?
Aber man findet den immer nie, weil er auch ein sehr kleines
Magazin ist. Es geht immer unter
und steht dann immer nicht bei den internationalen Magazinen,
sondern irgendwo an der Kasse und ich suche
darauf da immer rum und so, dann fühle ich mich eh schon ein bisschen pretentious
zu kaufen, weiss auch, ich werde es auch nicht lesen.
Nee. Ich habe auch mal Angst vor der Frage, ja, was sind
die Lieblingsartikel und ich renne aus dem Laden raus.
Blöde Angst, weil diese Frage wird nie kommen, wurde auch noch nie gestellt.
Aber keine Ahnung, und deswegen da, bei so einem Bob-Dillen-Magazin, glaube ich, traut man sich noch weniger zu fragen.
Haben Sie das Bob-Dillen-Magazin von Richard?
Deswegen bring einen Podcast raus.
Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, vor zwei Jahren mal versucht, eine Magazinphase zu starten.
Bei mir ist es ja anders als bei dir.
Bei dir fliegt das ja zu.
Musenhaft wirst du geküsst und dann hast du wieder eine Phase, die neue Erleuchtung, das neue Du kommt auf dich herab.
Bei mir ist das anders.
Ich muss in die Persönlichkeitsmine gehen und richtig hacken und richtig suchen und richtig Arbeit reinstecken.
Und vor zwei Jahren dachte ich, jetzt ist es wieder an der Zeit.
Ich glaube, ich habe hier eine Ader gefunden, ich will ran und wollte die Magazinphase starten und habe gelesen das Mare Magazin. Ein Magazin, in dem es ums Meer geht und alles, was mit dem Meer zu tun hat. Schifffahrt, Fischfahrt, Fischerei, Tischerei, Meeres, Tische, Riffeiffe, Aquarien oder war Aquarien zu weit weg?
Nein, Aquarien nicht, das ist die Antithese zum Meer.
Ja, Atolle, Meeresbusen, sowas in der Richtung.
Atolle, Riffe, Bay, eine richtig gute Bay.
All das, Muräne, Buchten, ja, schön, und das alles, eine Kombüse, Kombüse, ja. All das, ja, gut. So, und dann dachte ich mir, das ist es doch eigentlich, weil die Meere sind eigentlich in der Überzahl, es gibt mehr mehr als Land, deswegen dachte ich mir eigentlich clever, ins Meer zu investieren. Das glaube ich immer nicht. Das ist so wie gefühlte Temperatur. Ich glaube das nicht. Also es ist gefühlt gibt es Meerland. Weil wer vermisst denn das Meer? Hat da jemand ein Marsband quer durchs Meer gezogen oder so? Das geht ja nicht. Ich glaube, das war so eine Pima Daumen Sache. Aber da gab es auch diesen Film, die Vermessung der Welt. Ich glaube, da hat man mal ordentlich ein Marsband angelegt. Aber ich weiß, ich habe den Film nie gesehen. Da gibt es ab dem Film nicht gesehen wir schauen den nicht an was sind wir für arrogante Arschlöcher da gibt es einen Film, der beantwortet all unsere Fragen und wir sitzen hier und schauen das zwölfte Mal Arrival an und nicht die Vermessung der Welt wie vermessen ist das eigentlich was machen wir eigentlich mit unserem Leben Arrival ist toll Arrival ist ein super, aber hat nichts mit dem Meer zu tun. Und ich interessiere mich eigentlich für mehrere. Und irgendwo nach so drei Ausgaben musste ich mir eingestehen, dass mir mehrere letzten Endes doch einfach scheiss egal sind. Und klar, Plankton und so, das ist interessant, die Bilder sind toll, von hier Klippe, schaue ich mir gern an in Schottland. und, aber ich bin einfach ... Ich weiß auch nicht genau, weil Bücher sind ja toll. Weil Bücher, egal ob du sie liest oder nicht, du stellst sie ins Regal und wirkst klug. Oh, nee, jetzt verrenzt du dich. Nee, ich bin ganz felsenfest, standfest. Ich bin gespannt. Das können Magazine nicht leisten. Ja, ich wusste nicht. Nein, nein, nein, das können Magazine...
Ich habe noch nie gesehen, dass jemand regaleweise Magazine hat. Magazine werden entsorgt, die sind einfach Druckerzeugnis, die sind nicht für die Ewigkeit. Erstmal habe ich einen schönen Magazinständer, lustigerweise aus dem Laden Magazin, aber das gehört jetzt hier nicht hin. Was ist ein Magazinständer, so wie im Shop? Nee, so ein Zeitungsständer, es gibt ja so einen Zeitungsständer, so ein Ziermoniker-artiger Ständer, wo du halt Druckerzeugnisse reinlegen kannst. So ein Zickzack-Ding. So ein Zickzack-Ding. Und da habe ich alle, weil ich hätte eine Zeit lang den New Yorker abonniert, also lächerlich wenig davon gelesen. Ich dachte auch, naiverweise hatte ich angenommen, aber das darf man jetzt nicht zu laut sagen, dass da viel mehr Bilder drin sind. Aber kaum Bilder. Das ist ja immer die Hoffnung. Nur in Textwände. Und dann habe ich aber schon für hundert bis zwei Euro Dollar dieses Abonnement abgeschlossen. Dann kommt das erste Druckerzeugnis zu mir nach Hause, wahrscheinlich auch bei dem grossen Teich irgendwie geworfen worden, von einem Riesenkatapult. Na klar. Und dann kommt es bei mir an und ich mache es auf und merke, bei Ausgabe eins, scheiße, keine
Bilder, keine Bilder.
Die Rezepte, das ist das
Kreuzworträtsel. Kreuzworträtsel, ja
stimmt. Stimmt, das ist doch berühmt, das
New Yorker Kreuzworträtsel.
Ah nein!
Das war auch mein Denkfehler, aber es gibt auch das New Yorker Kreuzworträtsel,
aber das gibt es nur online, meine ich, weiss ich nicht
genau. Das Cover war aber schön und deswegen habe ich
jetzt alle, habe ich diesen Zickzack-Ständer gemacht, teilweise auch in so einem Bücherregal, gibt's unten noch so ein Ding, da hab ich die hingelegt. Und ich finde, die machen meine Wohnung schöner, die New Yorker. Übrigens auch, was ich mitgenommen habe beim Knives Out, bei Ransom, der coole Character, hat ja auch bei sich zu Hause sehr viele New Yorker-Magazine rumliegen. Ah, da konntest du nicht direkt mit dem Spoiler, bösewichtigen. So, wo willst du deinen Popschluss in den Griff bekommen? Du hast Popschlussprobleme. Das funktioniert nicht. Du hast Pps. Aber du sammelst Magazine und hältst die direkt allen Besuchern direkt ins Gesicht und denkst dir, so macht man es. Genau, weil ich, ja, weil ich lese die ja nicht und dann habe ich überlegt, was kann ich jetzt damit noch anfangen, praktischer Wert, ah, ich wirke belesener, kultivierter, interessierter und habe die jetzt ausgestellt. Aber apropos Rätsel in Magazinen, ich habe ja bei einem Callcenter gearbeitet und das war ja eine betrügerische Firma, die alles mögliche gemacht hat, womit man immer schnell Geld verdienen kann. Wir lernen jetzt mittlerweile sehr viel über den kriminellen Florentin und seine Vergangenheit. Ja, ja, ja, absolut. Ich bin jetzt mittlerweile ... Wahlplakate überklebt und jetzt kommt das. Ja, jetzt verjährt das halt alles. So, jetzt verjährt das halt alles. Ist ja irgendwie eine versteckte Kamera. Du kriegst deinen Popschuss. Wie lange machen wir diesen Drecks-Podcast schon? Du kriegst es nicht hin, diesen Popschuss festzusurren. Warte mal, so. Fällt immer so lustig auf ihn drauf.
Ja.
So, jetzt verjährt das halt alles.
Und deswegen kann ich das jetzt alles erzählen, deswegen kommt das langsam raus.
Und ich war eigentlich schon immer kriminell, aber durfte es rechtlich nicht sagen.
Ja.
Und dann ein Teil dieser kriminellen Machenschaften war auch Rätsel für Zeitungen.
Mhm.
Und da ging es ja auch darum, dann das Rätsel. Unlösbare Sudokus, ich wusste es.
Die Betrüger. Die Betrüger. Moment, der grösste Verbrecherring ist aufgeflogen. Moment mal, da heißt es zehn Fehler finden, aber es sind nur neun im Bild. Tausende Geschädigte. Und da ging es eben auch darum, diese Rätsel zu machen, unter anderem diese klassischen Suchbilder, finde zehn Fehler. Genau. Und dann haben die irgendwie die Grafiker das gemachtes Bild unter zehn Sachen verändert und dann wussten die aber immer nicht, ob das zu schwer ist. Und dann sind sie zu mir gegangen und dann musste ich das testweise lösen und dann hieß es immer so, Florentin, du hast jetzt drei Minuten Zeit, das ist ungefähr so der Zeitraum, der in Ordnung ist. Gab es andere Tester oder warst du der einzige? Ich war der einzige Tester, der einzige Tester. Aber jetzt wissen die ja nicht, was deine Expertise ist.
Vielleicht bist du der beste Wimmelbildfinder, Suchfehlerbildfinder der Welt. Und ich stand, glaube ich, nie wieder unter so einem Druck. Weil du weisst, okay, ich bestimme gerade den Schwierigkeitsgrad für Suchbilder in der ganzen Nation. Entweder bin ich zu schlecht und alle haben ein sehr einfaches Rätsel, oder ich bin zu gut, alle haben ein sehr schweres Rätsel. Ich bin jetzt das Züngler an der Waage. Das ist eine riesige Verantwortung. Und dann kam erschwerend hinzu, dass ich versucht habe, natürlich möglichst gut zu sein. Was natürlich für den Tester schlecht ist, weil es dann zu schwer ist, aber ich dachte, ich will einfach die beiden Grafiker beeindrucken. Und jetzt kommt ein zweiter Teil meiner Persönlichkeit hinzu, der jetzt zu einem teuflischen Gebräu an Inkompetenz vermischt wurde. Der zweite Teil ist, kleiner Funfigur über meine Familie, meine Familie hat eine relativ ausgeprägte 3D-Tradition. Was heißt das? Nee, diese Frage hat sich mir jetzt nicht gestellt. Zoweit für mein Onkel macht gerne 3D-Fotos. Das heißt, er macht zum Beispiel ein Foto, rennt dann zehn Meter weiter nach links und macht noch ein Foto von derselben Kirche. Die aber abgerissen wurde in den zehn Sekunden. Und dann ist es ein großes Fragezeichen. Das muss ja schon gleichzeitig einigermaßen entstehen. Genau, und dann werden die so entwickelt wie Dia-Bilder, also so durchsichtige Filmbilder, und dann werden die in so zwei Kästen gesteckt, und dann hältst du dir diese Kästen jeweils vor das eine und das andere Auge, und dann hast du halt diesen 3D-Effekt. Hat der einen Instagram-Account? Leider nein. Geht nicht, nämlich, man braucht zwei Handys. Man braucht zwei Instagram-Accounts, ja. Theoretisch, glaube ich, könnte es schon gehen. Das ist eigentlich sehr lustig. Weil er hat immer gesagt, er selber, mein Onkel, ist da so erfahren, der kann das sich auch nebeneinander ausdrucken. Auf einem Blatt Papier nebeneinander ausdrucken und angucken und er sieht das 3D, weil er fokussiert dann halt hinter das Blatt und bla bla bla. Und für uns Idioten musste man aber immer diese Dia-Methode machen, damit wir das sehen können. Und der hat auch zum Beispiel gesagt, für ihn ist es total leicht, diese Finde-10-Fehler-Bilder zu machen, weil die sind ja direkt nebeneinander. Und dann schaut er die auch so an wie ein 3D-Bild, legt die also sozusagen in seinem inneren Auge übereinander und dann sieht er diese zehn Fehler, Zitat, aufflackern. Und dann dachte ich mir, holy crap, dieser Mensch ist das Nächste einem Superhelden, was ich jemals real sehen würde. Der Mann kann durch 3D-Sicht Suchbilder, er scannende Augen, er scannende Fehler raus. Er scannende Fehler. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr diese 3D-Bücher kennt. Aber ist er so Sherlock Holmes-mäßig unterwegs und sagt so, oh, du hast einen Zahnpastverfleck an deinem Mund, das sagt, du bist ein bisschen zu spät aufgestanden, bist ein bisschen mehr als den Termin vergessen. Nee, nur 3D-Bilder. Also nur bei zwei Bildern, die identisch eigentlich sein müssten, nebeneinander dann flackern. Okay, es ist ein sehr spezifischer Superheld, aber... Und er ist natürlich ein großer Freund der Schifffahrt, weil wenn du mit einem Schiff vorbeifährst an der Brücke, dann bleibst du einfach stehen, wo du bist auf dem Schiff und machst ein Foto und dann ein paar Sekunden später noch ein Foto und dann hast du den 3D-Effekt, ohne dich selbst bewegen zu müssen. Genial. Also nicht nur ein 3D-Fotografier ist, auch faul. Also er ist auch zu faul, um noch die Schritte zu gehen. Okay, alles klar. Aber das war tatsächlich immer, weil ich war oft mit dem im Urlaub, und das war immer lustig anzusehen, weil wenn du zum Beispiel so eine Kirche fotografierst mit ganz vielen Menschen davor, dann musst du ja möglichst die Bilder so machen, dass die Menschen sich nicht bewegen in der Zeit. Ganz kurz, Leute. Ja, genau. Und alle dreitausend... Arez, Arez, s'il vous plait, Arez, s'il vous plait, S'il vous plait. Entweder das, oder du versuchst, so schnell es geht, diese zehn Meter zurückzulegen und ganz schnell das zweite Foto zu machen. Wow, ich bin amazed von deinem Onkel. Ich habe so viele Fragen an ihn. Und das war immer toll anzusehen, weil wir schauen uns die Kirche an und alles toll und der immer klick, bababababababababab, klick und dann der, ah, verdammt, dieser scheiß Kinderwagen jetzt. Und also fantastisch. Und es ist aber tatsächlich sehr, sehr cool. So, aber kann es sein, dass du jetzt durch deine 3D-Familie schon so viel Expertise auf diesem Feld auch des Fehlerfindens, Fehlersuchens mitbekommen hast, dass du viel zu gut warst für diesen Test. So. Und mein Problem ist, ich konnte das nie. Das mit den Dierboxen habe ich gesehen. Du warst ein großer Fan von Simpsons, 2D, niemand hat es verstanden, alle haben dich gehasst. Ich liebe Schach, auch 2D-Spiel, ja, alles 2D. Und meine Familie stand da Kopfschüttel und hat vorher gesagt, nein, spiel doch Super Mario 64. 3D ist die Zukunft. Und wir hatten zum Beispiel auch immer, ich weiß nicht, ob man das noch kennt, diese 3D-Bücher, wo dann so ganz merkwürdige Muster sind und man kann das so dreidimensional angucken, dann sieht man so ein dreidimensionales Pferd oder so. Nie gesehen, nie gemacht, ich habe das immer für Betrug gehalten, dass da nichts drinsteckt. Ich fand auch immer, dass der Aufwand nicht das Resultat rechtfertigt. Ich kann es nicht bewerten, ich habe das Resultat nie gesehen. Ich fand es, nee, generell, bei allen Dingen, die mit 3D zu tun haben, finde ich, rechtfertigt dieser ernüchternde Eindruck am Ende nicht den Aufwand, den man betreibt, um das hinzubekommen. Ich habe noch nie im 3D-Film gesessen und gesagt, wow, jetzt lohnt es sich dafür, diese sehr unkomfortable Brille auf der Nase zu haben die ganze Zeit. Mir wird es schlecht. Geht mir ähnlich, tatsächlich muss ich sagen, das einzige, wo ich 3D wirklich cool fand, war bei meinem Onkel, als wir diese Fotos angeguckt haben. Weil der hat dann halt so ein, das Coole ist halt so Motive, die halt super viele Details haben. So wenn du jetzt so einen Baum mit ganz vielen Blättern fotografierst, dann siehst du die halt alle einzelnen, die einzelnen Blätter in verschiedenen Ebenen und so. Und das ist schon echt cool. Und trotzdem habe ich es nie geschafft, auch zu seiner Enttäuschung, nie diese 3D-Bilder zu sehen. Und jetzt ganz kurz, wir schneiden wieder fünf Jahre nach vorne in das Büro des Callcenters, wo ich diese beiden Bilder vorgesetzt bekomme. Und ich entscheide, aus einem Wahnsinn heraus, in dem Moment die Technik meines Onkels zu versuchen, um Versuche, diesen 3D-Effekt zu erzwingen mit diesen beiden Bildern, die mir vorgesetzt wurden. Ich starre also mit enormer Intensität auf dieses Bild, weiß gar nicht, was ich machen soll, meine Augen denken sich so, keine Ahnung, was hier passieren soll. Es geht zu schnell. Es geht zu schnell. Wie so ein Kind, was noch Stützräder benutzt, auf so ein Fahrrad zu setzen, so einen Berg hinunter zu schubsen. Das machst du gerade mit den Augen. Ich versuche also, hinter das Blatt zu fokussieren, vor das Blatt zu fokussieren, versuche hinter mir den Monitor zu fokussieren und dann auf das Blatt zu schauen und währenddessen stehen die Grafiker neben mir, denken, was passiert hier gerade?
Und ich merke, wie mir richtig, richtig schwindelig wird.
Oh ja, okay.
Mir wird richtig schwindelig.
Auch vergessen, dass du atmen hast auch.
Und mir wird wirklich fast schwarz vom Kopf, alles verschwimmt.
Und ich muss, ich sag den beiden, oh scheiße, mir wird richtig schwindelig.
Ich seh gar nichts mehr, ich seh nichts mehr, ich finde keinen einzigen Fehler, die Zeit ist abgelaufen, ich habe keinen einzigen Fehler gefunden von diesem Bild. Und die meinen, ja okay, krass, das ist vielleicht echt zu schwer, dann machen wir es nochmal neu. Und dann fehlt ein ganzes Haus, Kinderrätsel. Man kennt das ja, die drei Fehler sieht jeder sofort, die sind super offensichtlich, da wird es schwerer, aber ich habe nichts gefunden, weil ich in dem Moment eher dachte, nee, ich versuche meinen gesamten Sehapparat zu revolutionieren, ihm was abzuverlangen, was er noch nie konnte. Aber wieso häufig eine Metapher fürs Leben, du wolltest so sehr geliebt werden, dass du dich verstellt hast. Richtig. Du hast jemandem versucht zu sein, der du nicht bist, du hast versucht eine Fähigkeit anzuwenden, die du nicht hasst und bist dann klärlich versagt. Hast auf den Tisch gekotzt, weil dir so schlecht wurde vom Fokus rumfokussieren.
Das heißt an alle...
Aber ich krieg diese ganze Geschichte noch nicht zusammen.
Also du hast im Callcenter gearbeitet.
In welcher Beziehung stand das Callcenter zu einem Magazin überhaupt mal?
Das war eine Firma, die hat allerhand mögliche Sachen gemacht, um Geld zu verdienen.
Die haben verschiedene Reisen ins Ausland bezahlt, die hatten irgendwelche medizinischen Scams am Laufen, die hatten eben diese Kontaktanzeigen, zu denen dieses Callcenter angeschlossen war. Ich habe ja Kontaktanzeigen aufgenommen. Ganz viele verschiedene Sachen. Und diese seriösen Fehlerbildmaler haben da aber für diese sehr unseriöse Firma gearbeitet. Nee, was heißt seriös, das waren einfach Grafiker, die dann die Schlagzeilen rumgeschoben haben und deren Aufgabe war halt auch, erstellt mal so ein Bild mit zehn Fehlern. Da muss man ja kein Probe, keine Korrifäe sein, um sowas hinzukriegen. Und dann kamen halt allerhand Sachen so. Ich hab da eh den randomsten Kram gemacht, da hieß es auch so, ja, du musst jetzt hier irgendwie 500 Sticker auf so Flyer kleben, random, nicht nachgefragt, was das ist, oder du musst jetzt hier einfach mal 2000 Umschläge zuschliessen. Du musst aber jetzt mal diesen Menschen da hinten umbringen, und das ist nicht hinterfragt. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Einen Tag waren lauter Models in der Firma, 20 davon saßen in meinem Callcenter. Auch beim Show-Rustplatz. Das istßen plötzlich überall rum, weil das war vor dem Oktoberfest in München und der wollte irgendeinen Scam machen mit, die verkaufen irgendwas und da hat er halt viele Models gebraucht, der Geschäftsführer, und da war so eine Art Casting da und die waren halt alle zeitgleich da und die saßen alle mit meinem Callcenter, das eh viel zu groß war, weil Callcenter war kein Business mehr, es war ein Callcenter ausgelegt für mehrere Leute, die da arbeiten, aber niemand benutzt mehr Kontaktanzeigen in Zeitungen. Deswegen waren die Plätze alle leer und ich saß alleine da. Und der Platz wurde halt genutzt von diesen wunderschönen Frauen, die da sich auf ihr Casting vorbereitet haben. Wir haben da ja mal angerufen, weisst du es noch? Hier, just in diesem Raum. Ja, weil wir hatten nämlich eine rote Liste von Anrufern, die abgewimmelt werden sollen.
Genau.
Und auf dieser roten Liste stand die New York Times. Genau. Und meine ganze Karriere dort habe ich mich gefragt, was zur Hölle geht hier vor, dass irgendein scheiß Münchner Betrügerding angstert vor der New York Times, als ob die jetzt in Scoop landen würden. Medium-sized Bavarian firm
does bad.
Er war so schwierig.
Von daher fanden wir es witzig und haben angerufen
und haben so getan, als wären wir von den New York Times.
Was war das Ergebnis? Weiß nicht mehr.
Keine Erinnerung mehr. Hört euch die Folgen an.
Ich glaube, es ist niemand rangegangen.
Ich weiß noch, dass sich was piepen musste.
Ich glaube, da ist jemand rangegangen.
Das weißt du noch, weil es ein bisschen Aufwand gemacht hat. Wir haben heute ein ganzes Segment, dass er auch rausgestrebt und nicht vielleicht, dass er was piepen muss. Aber gute Idee für Richard vielleicht, weil ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie ich ein Bob Dylan Magazin füllen soll, überhaupt eine Ausgabe. Mach doch einfach in Ausgabe 1 schon mal so ein großes Fehlersuchbild. Ja, genau. So eine Doppelseite, links hast du ein altes Albumcover von Bob Dylan, rechts auch, aber, und hier kommt der Twist, man ahnt es schon, zehn Fehlerchen. Ja, und vielleicht als Tipp die Bilder untereinander, damit die 3D-Freaks nicht cheaten. Ja, wohl, können es seitlich halten. Ehrlich gesagt, ich will aber durch Deutschland laufen und überall das Bob-Dylan-Magazin sehen, mit Leuten, denen schlecht wird, weil die diesen Trick anwenden wollen. Ich hoffe, also einerseits, vor allem, wir würden Werbung schalten. Sofort, sofort. Wahrscheinlich finanzierst du dich auch durch Werbung. Wir machen so ein großes Podcast-Ufo oder für uns mit so einer Uhr oder so was. So eine Magazinwerbung machen wir. Ja, für unseren Eistee oder was haben wir gerade in Produktion? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ich finde gut, so eine Uhr und da drunter steht das Podcast-Ufo. Aber es hat so eine, oder so eine Giorgio Armani-artige. Oder einfach eine Rolex und darunter steht das Podcast-Ufo. Man weiß nicht genau, was man machen soll. Richard, schreib uns, wir sind bereit zu werben in deinem Magazin, wir sehen deinen guten Markt. Und ganz kurz nochmal ein riesiges, riesiges Sorry an alle Leute da draußen, die um das Jahr 2011 herum vielleicht ein zu schweres Suchbild in der Zeitung gefunden haben und daran verzweifelt sind. Vielleicht war ich daran schuld, weil ich zu dumm war, auch nur einen einzigen Fehler zu finden und deswegen wurde es so schwer gemacht. Zu leicht. Soll ich dir aufmachen? Zu leicht, du hast recht. Du hast völlig recht. Also sorry, falls ihr 2011 gelangweilt war. Gelangweilt war. Zu leicht. Ja, oder jetzt mal, jetzt mal, kann ja böse enden, sowas. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du dir in der Verantwortung sicher bist. Aber jetzt angenommen, da ist jetzt nicht so ein Kind dran und findet diese Fehler, weil es dann so leicht war, wahnsinnig schnell. Ja. Er rennt zu den Eltern. Überschätzt. Und sagt, ich habe das in zwei Sekunden gelöst. Und die Eltern sagen, was, unser Kind ist hochbegabt. Denken Eltern, er bestimmt auch.
Ich würde auch von meinen Kindern wahrscheinlich sofort auch hoffen,
weil es so ein Wunschgedanke ist, mein Kind ist hochbegabt.
So, und dann wird es auf so eine hochbegabten Schule geschickt und so,
New York, Stipendium, und dann ist es da das schlechteste Kind von allen
und wird gemobbt und fliegt runter.
Nicht, weil es das Klassensum was findet.
Nee, er hat gar keinen Bock, findet nichts, kann auch nichts,
versteht auch nicht, was da abgeht. Alles nur wegen deinem Dreckswimmelbild. Ja, das tut mir echt leid. Also, falls ihr diese Person seid und jetzt irgendwo in Harvard sitzt mit elf oder so. Warnlich überfordert, mit elf in Harvard. In so einem Quantenphysikkurs und ihr versteht kein Wort, dann sorry. Sorry. Sorry an der Stelle, tut mir leid, schreibt eine Nachricht. Wie wenig schlimm muss das sein, was du gemacht hast, damit deine Entschuldigung einfach das Wort sorry ist. Ja, das stimmt. So schriftlich. Ja, könnte man auch eine Tabelle machen. Wir arbeiten ja gerade an einem modernen Knigge, einem Büchlein, Booklet. Einen hochmathematischen, ohne Bilder, das sagen wir vorab, kein einziges Bild drin. Einfach so hochmathematische, viele Skalen, viele Fussnoten auch. Wir haben ja schon die Skala gemacht, so mit Never, Sometimes, Maybe, so diese Sachen. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, ab wann entschuldigt man sich für was? Was ist denn die schlimmste, was ist denn die höchste Stufe? Jopp, Jopp und Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, Jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, jopp, so ein zu spät kommen, fände ich schon, ist eher, Entschuldigung. Ja, unterste Stufe ist für mich S-R-Y. Das ist für mich die allerunterste Stufe. Darüber kommt Sorry, dann Schuldigung, dann Tschuldigung. Ja, ich finde das ist der Strich. Entschuldigung, genau. Dann Entschuldigung. Aber jetzt, nee, ich glaube, das geht gerade zu schnell. Weil ich glaube nicht, dass Entschuldigung besser ankommt als Sorry. Sorry schafft es schon. Apologies. Andere Sprache wechseln einfach. Tut mir leid, würde ich wirklich in der Mitte ansetzen. Tut mir leid, finde ich schon ausgesprochen. Drei Wörter aufwand. Tut mir leid, tut mir wirklich leid. Tut mir von Herzen leid. Ja, da sind wir schon in einer Bewerbung und Absage. Da sind wir schon echt hoch. Ich bin untröstlich? Wo sind wir da? Nee, stimmt das überhaupt? Entschuldigt man sich damit? Nee, ne? Ich bin untröstlich. Doch schon. Entschuldigen ist eh eine weirde Form. Als weirde Form. Ja, eigentlich sagt man ja, ich bitte um Entschuldigung. Entschuldigung selbst ist ja eigentlich nur eine verkürzte Form von. Ich flehe um Verzeihung. Das ist mir das Höchste, oder? Ich werfe mich vor dir auf den Boden, küsse deine Füsse und flehe um Verzeihung. Ich flehe dich an. Verzeihung. Verzeihung. Aber Verzeihung ist höflich. Jetzt machen wir vor allem unseren Onkelwitzfreunden 3D-Grafen auf und reisen auch in der Zeit zurück, weil da war Verzeihung noch ein wichtigeres Wort als sorry. Aber wenn du jetzt so durch die Bahn läufst, da rempelt jemand an. Es tut mir leid, ich habe mich verrannt. Ich sage sorry. Es tut mir leid, ich war nicht ich selbst. Aber sagst du dann sorry oder sorry? Wo ist der Unterschied jetzt? Aussprache. Deutsche Aussprache, englische Aussprache. Sorry. Oder sorry. Sorry. Nee, ich sage dann sorry. Sorry. S-O-R-R-I. Sorry. Wir haben die schlecht. Ja, schwierig. Schwierig. Bist du gut im Entsch im Entschuldigen oder bist du gut genug Schauspieler, um dich auch entschuldigen zu können, ohne dass du es meinst? Ja, doch, doch. Ich bin ein sozialer Schauspieler. Wie viel Prozent deiner Entschuldigungen in deinem Leben bisher hast du tatsächlich gemeint und wie viel waren gelogen? Oh, jetzt können wir das sogar noch grösser machen. Wie viele Dinge habe ich überhaupt jemals so gemeint, wie ich sie gesagt habe? Okay. Und ich glaube, ich bin wirklich ein Chamäleon höchsten Grades, ein Schauspieler, ein sozialer Schauspieler mit Masken, die ich mir aufsetze und vom Kopf reiße. Wer bin ich? Ja, kann mich mal jemand finden? Wirklich. Das finde ich nicht schlecht. Finde mich. Ich will, dass du mich findest. Ich weiss selber nicht, wer ich bin, ich will, dass du mich findest.
Es könnte ein schöner Rom-Com werden.
Stefan Tietze, finde mich.
Es gibt ja Leute, die dann so auf so Retreats
gehen und so, um sich zu finden.
Hat da mal jemand gesagt,
ich war nicht begeistert von dem, was ich da
gefunden habe. Ja, genau. Ich habe mich gefunden,
habe mich aber wieder in dem Retreat zurückgelassen
und bin jetzt wieder der Alte.
Ich habe mich wieder ad acta gelegt.
Ich bin jetzt wieder der Alte. Weil manchmal will man sich vielleicht nicht finden, ist ja auch okay. Nee. Magst du was, das tief in dir schlummert? Nee, gar nicht, aber die Frage ist, darf ich früher abreisen, wenn ich mich schon vor Ende des Retreats gefunden habe? Und muss ich trotzdem den ganzen Preis zahlen, das ist meine Frage. Er geht zu diesem Aloha-Lord, der die meisten Blumenketten um den Hals hat und sagt, Entschuldigung, ich habe mich jetzt doch schon gefunden nach zwei Wochen. Kann ich gehen? Bin ich frei? Aber der Typ, den du angesprochen hast, ist natürlich so ein weises Orakel, der würde dann sowas sagen wie, das sind immer die ersten Anzeichen von jemandem, der sich in Wahrheit noch nicht gefunden hat.
Okay, weil ich habe jetzt morgen diesen Tauchkurs und ich wollte wissen, ob ich da das Geld zurückkriegen kann, wenn ich jetzt heute Abend abreise oder weil ich habe mich einfach gefunden. Florentin-Son, folgen Sie mir in die Hot-Stone-Massage für 39,99 Euro kostet die für Sie und wir finden Sie wirklich. Okay, weil ich habe mich ja gestern gefunden irgendwie, ich habe gemerkt, ich bin ein introvertierter Typ, der große Träume hat. Und das reicht mir, mir reicht das eigentlich. Ja, okay, dann kriegen Sie das Geld zurück. Okay, danke. Er ist der Erste, der sich jemals selber gefunden hat. Ja, ich habe auch ein bisschen Angst. Ich habe aber, wo du gerade meintest, du wolltest diesen Grafikern so sehr gefallen, ich kann das so nachvollziehen, dieses Gefühl, jemandem zu gefallen und dadurch im Prinzip ein schlechteres Leben zu führen.
Ja, ich habe ja erzählt vor ein paar Wochen, ich habe jetzt so eine Weinphase, habe ich nicht wirklich, ich habe nur mal hier so einen Weinhändler aufgesucht und hatte ein gutes Gespräch mit dem, um Wein zu kaufen.
So, jetzt wollte ich dem aber so sehr beeindrucken mit meinem Wissen über Wein, was ich nicht habe, dass ich im Endeffekt Weine gekauft habe, von denen ich wusste, dass ich die nicht mag. Weil ich wollte so sehr ihm gefallen und wollte so sehr, dass er denkt, der kennt sich aber ziemlich gut aus für sein Alter und für die Zeit, die er in Weine gesteckt hat. Ich wollte im Prinzip hören, ich bin der begabteste Weintester der Geschichte. Und dann hat er so Sachen gesagt wie, was magst du denn und so, und jetzt wollte ich dann nicht sagen, Cola, Dr. Pepper, fiel ich mega geil. Also wenn das so ein bisschen schmecken könnte, wäre das gut. Sondern hab dann halt so mich verrannt in Gebieten, die ich schon mal aufgeschnappt habe. Und Rebsorten, von denen ich glaube, dass die komplex sein könnten. Das war aber direkt all in, ne? Also da gibt es keinen Aufbau, sondern nichts mehr. Ich bin all in gegangen und hab dann Weine bekommen. die sind schon ein bisschen komplexer, aber du musst auch ein bisschen was zahlen.
Und ich dachte, statt das Schwitzen in diesem Laden und habe dann sehr teure Weine gekauft, die nicht meinem Geschmack entsprechen, weil ich ihm nicht übers Herz gebracht habe, zu sagen, dass ich so einen basic Dressgeschmack habe, dass mir reicht der Grauburgunder von der Tanke, habe ich mir nicht getraut. Ich finde die Vorstellung toll, dass es fortgeschrittene Weine gibt, dass es komplexe Weine gibt, wo man sich erstmal hinarbeiten muss. Man schmeckt das schon. Das ist schon fortgeschritten. Ja genau, ich habe nämlich eine Geschichte erzählt, da habe ich mich verrannt, wie ich dann in Berlin meinen sehr teuren Wein probiert habe. Und dann habe ich gesagt, wie er mir geschmeckt hat, er kannte auch den Namen und so, und ich habe gesagt, ah, nicht gut, war nicht so mein Ding, war mir ein bisschen zu komplex.
Und er hat gesagt, nee, der ist eigentlich sehr gefällig.
Der will ja so gefallen.
Und ich dachte mir, fucking hell, die Chance war 50-50.
Aber was heißt denn komplex?
Heißt komplex einfach, dass es mehr verschiedene Geschmäcker sind
oder ist einfach Pfirsich komplexer als Himbeere?
Und wenn Wein nach Pfirsich schmeckt, sagt man, ui, ui, ui, Pfirsich.
Ja, erstens, ich warte ja immer noch auf meine grossen Aromen, die ich riechen kann. Ja, wo sind die denn? Ja, du wolltest sie bestellen. Ich hab sie nicht bestellt. Ja, jetzt werden Sie. Das kostet halt irgendwie über 100 Euro, diese Aromenpalette. Wofür machen wir denn diese Drecks-Coro-Werbung die ganze Zeit? Hä? Okay, gut, ich bestell eine. So, Steck-Coro ist mittlerweile auch schon im Angebot. Aber was haben die nicht? Keine Werbung. Ja, mache ich auf jeden Fall, dann können wir mal eine Live-Verkostung machen im Podcast, was natürlich für euch eher Medium ist, weil es nicht schmeckt, aber können wir trotzdem machen. Stimmt, das ist der schlechteste Ort dafür eigentlich, aber. Aber dann kannst du endlich mal vorankommen mit deiner Weine. Ich will dich auch unterstützen in deinen Phasen. Ja, hoffe ich. Ja, nicht immer so negativ meinen Phasen gegenüber sein. Aber ich glaube, komplexe Weine sind, bieten mehr für den ganzen Mund. Da sind mehr Noten drin. Du hast halt quasi in der ersten Nase hast du was anderes als in der dritten, da kommt dann noch was durch, wo du vorher nicht mit gerechnet hast. Ich zum Beispiel habe jetzt nur eine Nase, also ich bin Anfänger. Es gibt vier Nase. Gegensatz zu den Experten. Du bist wirklich ein Anfänger dann, wenn du nicht von den vier Nasen weißt. Gibt es wirklich so einen legendären Weinkenner, der es bis zu sieben Nasen geschafft hat? Ich glaube, es gibt keine sieben Nasen. Wo man sagt so, Legende besagt von dem einen, der hat sich zurückgezogen. Wie so ein Vishnu-artiger, siebennäsiger Sommelier. Es transzendiert so, die Weine, die wir trinken, schmecken für uns nach Benzin, das können wir gar nicht auseinanderfleddern, was der da alles drin sieht. Nee, Wein ist wie Jazz, also Musik. Also saulangweilig. Also saulangweilig und nervig. Musik ist wie Musik, also man muss sich schon ein bisschen reinhören in Musik, um irgendwann komplexe Musik auch als schön zu empfinden. Ja, ich warte ja auf die Weihnachtsmarte gerade, die Wintermarte-Edition, die ich noch nicht überall finde. Gibt es da nicht so einen geilen Matehändler, wo man so hingehen kann und sagt, und dann fragt er, worauf hast du los? Ja, das wäre gut. Ich habe mal Bock auf was Komplexeres, fehlt aus Spanien oder so? Ja, okay, dann vielleicht mal die Ginger-Marte von Mio Mio. Ah, nee, kein Ginger-Mate-Fan. Okay. Die Bananen-Mate von Mio Mio? Nee, also ich bin eher Fan von so richtig purem Mate-Geschmack. Dann nehmen Sie die Club-Mate. Aber haben Sie vielleicht was Komplexeres da? Das ist leider ... Haben Sie noch mehr im Keller? Ja, ne, so vier Flaschen, die so nebeneinander stehen, in diesem Gewölbekeller. Wir haben noch ein paar Flaschen von 2009. Könnte ich Ihnen natürlich eine holen. Aber Marte hält sich doch gar nicht so lang. Das müssen Sie selber wissen. Niemand weiß, was danach passiert, was die nächste Entwicklungsstufe von Marte ist. Haben Sie nicht irgendwie was, Spanien würde ich vielleicht mal spannend oder Italien oder so? No, Senor. Nichts. Niente. Haben Sie noch einen Kellerflaschen oder sind das wirklich alle diese vier? Alle direkt da. Ja, ich habe ja meinen Matehändler, den ich ja schon vergrault habe, den Leckermatehändler, wo ich ja letztes Jahr schon so schlechtes Gewissen habe, weil den habe ich angesprochen, so, hey, kriegen Sie die Winteredition Clubmate. Und er meinte, was, was ist das, was ist das, verstehe ich nicht, kann ich nicht, kann ich nicht. Zusammengebrochen von. Gehe ich nicht hin. Ich darf es nicht. Und dann habe ich dem gesagt, weil hinten auf den normalen Mateflaschen ist ja Werbung für die Winteredition, er hat gesagt, ja die. Und dann meinte, ja schau ich mal an. Und ist auf der Winteredition Werbung für die normale Mate? Ich hoffe es, ja. Ich hoffe es, für die Sommeredition, die normale. Und dann hatte ich halt panische Angst, dass der es für fünf Kästen Winteredition bestellt, die niemand kauft und er bleibt darauf sitzen. Und ich habe mich darauf eingestellt und ich habe Geld gespart, dass ich ihm alle fünf Kästen abkaufen kann, wenn es so weit kommt. Aber er hat sie nicht bestellt. Nie bestellt. Ich habe immer reingelugt und habe geguckt, ob die Flaschen da sind, nicht da. Und auch dieses Mal, absolute Nullnummer, ich weiß nicht, wo man die findet. Und jetzt schreibt mir nicht im Internet bestellen, ich bestelle keine Getränke im Internet, ich will nicht, dass da irgendjemand die Treppe hochschleppen muss, mach ich nicht. So, das will ich schon selber machen. Nee, mach einfach ein bisschen. Was glaubt ihr denn, wenn ich zwei Kästen Mate bestell, bei mir im Keller stehen hab, die sind in zwei Tagen aufgetrunken, ich kann nicht mehr schlafen. Niemand sagt was. Ich stehe im Bett drei Wochen lang, ich werde nicht mehr schlafen, ich kann nicht leben, ich darf nicht zu viele Mate-Flaschen gleichzeitig haben. Weil jetzt kleiner Tipp für alle Leute und dich, aber auch Leute da draußen, die Bock haben
auf generell auch Wintereditionen.
Ja. Kleiner Tipp, was ihr einfach
reinkippen müsst, Zimt.
Zimt, so jetzt kommt
ein kleiner bisschen Advanced, wenn ihr ein bisschen
Advanced sein wollt. Zauberst gerade, ja. Bisschen
Orangen vielleicht, Orange ist auch
immer sehr weihnachtlich, bisschen Nelken
vielleicht noch, klein gerieben, bisschen
Nelken rein und für die ganz Abgefahrenen vielleicht so ein bisschen so eine Bratapfel-Note oder sowas.
Aber ich glaube, Weihnachten ist sehr einfach zu zaubern.
Du entzauberst, Stefan, du entzauberst. Ich glaube nicht, dass das ist, was die Leute gerade brauchen.
Es gibt ja auch einen Weihnachtsakkord, da gibt es auch ein ganz tolles Video, ich glaube, von Vox oder so drüber.
Adam Neely, glaube ich, hat da auch was gemacht.
Wer?
Adam Neely, unser Neely. Unser Neely. Unser Neely, der mittlerweile auch durchstattet, ne? Der so die New Yorker Musikszene für sich entdeckt hat. Ich habe einen tollen Twitch-Stellen entdeckt, wo ein Fahrradkurier einfach durch New York fährt und redet und ab und zu Musik anmacht. Und er fährt einfach durch New York und du bist mit ihm dabei, wie er Aufträge entgegennimmt.
Er arbeitet für Uber Eats auf dem Fahrrad.
Also streng genommen nicht Uber Eats, sondern Fahrrad Eats.
Und dann fährt er rum und dann siehst du, was er für Aufträge annimmt.
Dann hat er gesagt, Getränke mag er nicht so gern, weil die spillen.
Er hat sehr einfache Probleme und einfache Lösungen.
Und man sieht ein bisschen was von New York. Und und erklärt ein bisschen immer, wo hier was ist.
Das ist ja geil. Richtig geil.
Wie heißt der?
Stefan.
Weiß ich nicht.
Nur mit deinen Empfehlungen immer so. Ich hab da so viele gesehen mit so einem grossen weissen Hai.
Ja, und wie heißt der? Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Doch, hab ich mal aufgeschrieben.
Miki. M-I-E-K-I-I. Miki, Mikey wahrscheinlich. Mikey. Ich hab noch nie gesprochen. Mikey. Nee, aber das mach ich nicht. Ich find, das geht zu weit. Ich hab beschlossen, durch Köln zu gehen. Mit so einer GoPro. Er hat die auch so auf der Stirn. Das heißt, du läufst so wirklich so First Person, fährst du mit dem Fahrrad durch New York. Du durch Köln. Und ich durch langweilige Boring-Köln. Schön dein Kiez, Kölne-Kiez.
Ich habe auch nicht so einen Job. Heißt, ich laufe einfach nur,
ich spazier einfach. Ich gehe zum Bäcker,
ich gehe zum Geldautomaten. Ja, aber dann ist
vielleicht interessant, weil wenn du Livestreams, werden Leute
auf dich zukommen, dich entweder ausrauben
oder interessante Gespräche mit dir führen.
Das kann ja auch dein Konzept sein.
Warum geht es in New York nicht?
Weil es zu gross ist. Ich weiss es nicht.
Der ist jetzt schnell mit dem Fahrrad. Du kannst dir nicht mit dem Fahrrad hinterher rennen. Aber wenn du da dackelst, ich weiss ja, wie du spazierst, dann können dich Leute auch abpassen. Okay, Stefan rennt durch Köln, damit er nicht angeschmackt wird. Oder Stefan boostet boardet durch Köln und einfach die Hälfte des Streams ist im Krankenhaus. Die erste Hälfte ist noch fun, fun, fun, die ersten zehn Sekunden. Und dann sieht man so schwarz und dann sieht man so auf dem Asphalt liegend und dann sieht man so ein bisschen Blut, was so in den Bildvordergrund kommt.
Oder wie die Kamera so einen Hang runterrollt, minutenlang rollt, rollt, rollt, denkst du, wo in Köln war der denn?
Hey, ich freue mich sehr, euch zu meinem neuen Boosted-Bot.
Puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh, puh noch, mir und Julio down by the Schoolyard, läuft noch ballert, lautet ca. 100 noch so. Und du so, vielen Dank an Miliwan für den Sub. Die letzten Worte. Der Chat hat ganz andere Themen. Der Chat geht währenddessen über, oh, guckt ihr gerade Schach-WM, ja, krass, Bauer B4, blablabla. Das ist auch ein Stream, den ich mir anschauen würde. Ich habe überlegt, zu streamen. Ich fange an zu streamen. Ja, finde ich gut. Nächstes Jahr fange ich an zu streamen. Ich muss noch ein bisschen sparen auf einem guten Gaming-Laptop-PC. Und hast du einen Account? Ja, Esteban Tithos heisse ich, glaube ich, wie ich überall hieße. Nicht das Leute, die es jetzt klauen. Das ist immer gefährlich, wenn du sagst, wie willst du was machen, dann klauen Leute den Account. Ich will gerne lieber heißen, wie ich heiße, aber mal gucken. Und mein Plan wäre Non-Gaming. Non-Gaming. Einfach nur Blank-Comedy-Shit. Gucken was. Super. Ja, mal gucken. Blank. Blank. Blank, okay. Blank-Com. Blank Comedy. Finde ich gut. Nicht schlecht. Stefan Thieser startet durch. Du bist auch viel bei Twitch unterwegs. Stefan Twitcher oder wie? Stefan Twitcher, ja. Aber du machst ja auch viel auf Twitch. Ja, ich habe lange überlegt, ich habe lange überlegt, ob ich meinen Kanal Florentstream nennen will. Und wie stellt man sich das jetzt vor, wenn du sagst, du hast lange überlegt? Also wo hast du überlegt? Ich habe überlegt, weil ich will weg von Pommes Ruppel schon lange. Ach, du hast dich hier in einen Denksessel gesetzt. Habe ich, ich will weg von Pommes Ruppel und auch auf anderen Plattformen, aber leider sind viele Alternativen einfach schon weg. Habe ich mir auch teilweise selber weggenommen und habe das Passwort vergessen, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Habe ich auch, glaube ich. Treffantize bei Twitch ist, glaube ich, auch von mir. Ja, das ist immer bescheuert. Und Twitch hat da recht harte Regeln, dass wenn der Account irgendwie seit sechs Monaten nicht mehr aktiv ist und nur einen Follower hat oder so, dann löschen die das trotzdem nicht, weil der kann ja immer noch auch zuschauen. Der ist ja vielleicht nur Zuschauer und kein Creator. Aber das wissen die ja auch. Das wissen die ja auch und deswegen haben die auch geschrieben, bitte schreibt uns nicht an, dass wir Accounts löschen sollen. Wir wissen schon, wann Leute inaktiv sind und machen das dann selber.
Also mit einer sehr passiv-aggressiven Nachricht. Was bilden die sich denn ein? Ja, weil die wahrscheinlich jeden Tag Nachrichten kriegen, wie bitte löscht den, der hat nur einen abonniert und er sagt, ja, machen wir nicht, wir kennen uns besser aus mit der Materie als du. Und dann habe ich überlegt, wir können dich heißen. Dann dachte ich erst Florentin von Florent Stream, genial. Und dann ist es immer so, das ist oft bei mir die Entwicklung einer Idee, ich denke, sie ist richtig geil. Zwei Tage später denke ich mir, ja, die sind auch nicht so gut, aber besser als die Alternativen. Und einen Tag später nicht mehr, die ist richtig furchtbar, das kann ich nicht machen. Dann geht es wieder aufwärts und dann ist die absolute Unsicherheit. Und dann habe ich Hauke gefragt, Hauke, der auch streamt auf Twitch, und mit dem ich in All Most Delia hab ich gesagt habe, wie findest du Florent streamen? Der hat gesagt, scheusslich, grässlich. Da hab ich gesagt, gut, wenn Hauke das sagt, dann mach ich's nicht. Ich find's auch nicht so gut. Und jetzt hab ich mich ganz profan für den Namen Florentin Wedel entschieden, was einfach sehr förmlich klingt, aber so ist es nun mal. Aber so Eddie von den Rocket Beans, der dann auch sagt, herzlich willkommen bei Ada Live, das ist schon geil, da hast du direkt das Gefühl, du bist bei einer Show und so. Und das ist es ja im Prinzip, ist ja dein eigener kleiner TV-Sender. Und herzlich willkommen bei Florentin Wildes. Ja, gut, aber guck mal, Bob Dylan ist Bob Dylan. Ja, der ist jetzt auch kein Twitcher, sondern macht Musik. Ja, aber der würde sich auch nicht Dylan Dillonator nennen oder sowas oder Millie McDilly oder so, sondern ist halt einfach Bob Dylan. Der ist schon Bob, der hat schon Nicknames. So, und jetzt auf jeden Fall habe ich mich dafür entschieden und bin auch ganz zufrieden damit. Florentin David, Florent Stream, David Pascal Will, ich habe lange überlebt, Twitch, ja, wow. Verschiedene Varianten, aber na ja. Aber macht auf jeden Fall Spaß, ich bin gespannt, dich zu begrüßen. Die Möglichkeiten sind undenkbar, was alles angeht, was Podcasts, was Twitch angeht. Und deswegen muss man auch mal wirklich einfach neue Grenzen überschreiten. Ja, ich fand ja die Idee total cool, die es damals gab mit Twitch Plays Pokémon, wo du so Pokémon gespielt hast, aber es gab keinen Spieler, sondern der Chat hat den Charakter gesteuert. Immer mit welcher Befehl am häufigsten kam, also dann oben, unten, links, rechts. Fällt mir auch sehr gut, weil ich bin sehr faul. Ja, super. Und der Chat spielt dann quasi. Und es war halt so ein großes Projekt, so wie lange würde es dauern, bis die einfach das Spiel durchgespielt haben, weil es ist ja einfach Chaos, die Eingaben und so, mehr oder weniger. Und es hat super funktioniert, es hat irgendwie ein paar Tage gedauert und das hat total Spaß gemacht. Und ich dachte mir damals, wie man ja immer denkt als Medienmensch, denkt man ja, das ist die Zukunft. Der Content Creator an sich wird abgeschafft und ersetzt durch die Schwarmintelligenz. Was kommt als nächstes? Der Twitch-Chat spielt irgendein komplexeres Spiel durch, spielt Zelda durch, der Twitch-Chat komponiert einen ... Du hast einen ganz düsteren Essay-Blog auch. Ja, ich habe im Mick Jagger-Magazin einen Artikel geschrieben zum Thema Ist der Mensch obsolet? Ja. Und deswegen ist es überhaupt nicht so gekommen. Was ich gerade dachte, was geiler wäre, was das Coolste der Welt wäre, wäre ein Real-Life-Sims. Und zwar muss man eine reiche Familie finden, die bereit ist, ihr Haus komplett auszuräumen. Und dann braucht man so eine fliegende Drohnenkamera. Das Dach kommt weg. Und dann macht man so eine Drohnenkamera und dann können wir mit der Community das Haus einrichten. Mit echten Möbeln. Und die Community bringt die Möbel vorbei, oder was? Die bestellen die dahin. Also durch so Twitch-Votings wird dann gewählt, nee, die reiche Familie, die muss das schon selber. Die muss halt eine Familie finden, die sehr viel Geld hat. Die schmeissen alle ihre Möbel weg und bestellen neue, die sich der Chat wünscht. Genau. Okay. Klingt nach einem super Deal bis jetzt. Und unser Dach ist weg? Ja, das Dach ist weg. Okay, erstmal. Aber wenn man rauszoomt ... Wir warten auf Phase zwei. Erstmal ist nur das Dach weg. Gebt mal in den Pool jetzt, geht mal in den Pool. Und dann ... Aber Erdgeschoss wird ... Warum bauen sie die Leiter ab? Ja, also genau, Erdgeschoss. Also ich finde es geil, wenn man so ein typisches deutsches Einfamilienhaus irgendwo in der Pampa
und dann kann dann die Kommission das einrichten. Man muss eine reiche Familie finden, die bereit ist, sehr viel Geld auszugeben. Und das ist alles, man richtet einfach nur die Wohnung an. Naja, das ist doch das Geile bei Sims. Gut, ehrlich gesagt, wenn man dann noch eine Familie findet, die dann auch da einzieht und dann, und die Kameras bleiben bestehen. Ja, und die sich dann fragen, warum steht das Sofa falsch rum vor der Wand und warum sind hier 20 Kronleuchter im Bad? So und dann guckt man zu, wie die sich in ihrer dummen Wohnung zurechtfinden oder was. Genau. Das ist die, weil der Chat wird ja trollen, der wird ja irgendeine Quatschwohnung einrichten mit irgendwie 20 Billardtischen und du kannst dich in der Wohnung nahezu nicht bewegen, weil alles voller Billardtischen ist. Ja. Und die Familie hasst Billard, aber überall ist es. Und dann will ich auch sehen, wie die dann da einziehen und wie dann die Nachbarn zu Besuch kommen und so. Und die, da muss man natürlich, da muss man überlegen. Ja und wie sie vor allem bei Regen alle in ihren nassen Betten liegen, weil sie kein fucking Dach haben. Und alle Billardtische nass werden und die ganzen grünen Matten verziehen sich alle. Und selbst wenn man spielen wollen würde, was niemand will, könnte man nicht mehr. Könnte man nicht mehr. Dann muss man, da wird es dann die Idee langsam, da wird es erst brenzlig, man müsste dann quasi so Elektroden ans Hirn machen, um, wenn dann nämlich Endorphine ausgeschossen werden, dass man oben drüber, das kann man dann mit Einblendungen machen, dieses grüne Plus, wenn Sims was gut finden und die reden miteinander und finden was gut, es scheint über denen so ein grosses Schluss. Wie frechlich das wäre im echten Leben, wenn du mit jemandem redest und einfach, man unterhält sich normal und bei dir hat Minus, Minus, Minus, Minus, Minus, Minus, Minus, Minus, Minus, Minus. Warte mal, macht dir das Gespräch keinen Spaß? Doch, total! Minus, minus,us. Und dann so eine Denkblase, wo ich an ein Gespräch mit Auge im März denke. Ja, ähm, finde ich eine gute Idee. Du kannst ja mal gucken, dass du das auf die Beine stellst mit deinem Twitch-Kanal. Seid ihr eine reiche Familie, die ein Haus übrig hat und das Dach nicht mehr braucht, dann meldet
euch bei Stefan Esteban
Tizioso. Esteban
Twitcher und
ja, keine Ahnung, das Dach
aber gut, also es ist ein guter Einstiegsprojekt
für einen neuen, frischen Streamer.
Es gibt auch noch andere Ideen. Was ist deine Rolle dabei?
Du kommentierst das Ganze oder du machst dann so
wöchentliche Updates? Ich bin mit dem Chat
und trolle mit.
Noch ein Billardtisch. Okay,
ja, gute Idee.
Ich glaube, da sind viele Möglichkeiten noch nicht
ergründet bei Twitch.
Kriegt man auf jeden Fall. Aber bei Podcast
ja auch. Wir können ja auch hier nochmal. Wir machen hier
auf jeden Fall auch noch krasse Sachen. Dann haben wir so eine
Kamera in der Mitte, die sich erst langsam
dreht und je mehr Leute
Geld spenden, desto schneller dreht sich die Kamera. Bis irgendwann den Leuten so schlecht wird, dass sie abscheiden. Und dann wird es wieder langsamer. Okay. Es muss die Leute selber entscheiden müssen, ob sie gehen und dafür können alle anderen ein bisschen besser zugucken oder bleiben und allen geht es schlecht. Ein bisschen wie das Joker bei The Dark Knight. Ein bisschen, ja.
Mit den beiden Schiffen.
Wer zuerst drückt, der überlebt
dann auch. Aber wie soll man das verkabeln?
Wenn es sich dreht,
da bräuchte man dann so einen Bluetooth.
Ja, oder an einem Sockel unten
ist das Kabel und oben die Kamera.
Ja, aber das Kabel muss ja innerhalb des Sockels an die Kamera
gehen und wenn sich das immer dreht, dann... Das können wir vergessen.
Aber es muss gleichmäßig die Richtung wechseln, aber die Geschwindigkeit beibehalten. Wir tüfteln da mal ein bisschen. Ja, oder das Kabel dreht sich halt auch und der Empfängerrechner, sagen wir mal, dreht sich auch in der gleichen Geschwindigkeit. Das gesamte System dreht sich und dann per WLAN ins Internet. Das ginge. Ja, und alle, die jetzt die Augen verrollen und denken, warum können wir das nicht off-mic oder off-camera besprechen.
Nee, Innovation ist halt auch immer ein bisschen Arbeit. Und da müssen wir alle durch. Das ist jetzt behind the scenes. Wenn das in 100 Jahren das grösste Medienereignis des 21. Jahrhunderts ist, dann freut ihr euch, dass ihr dieses Backscenes-Material habt. Genau, richtig. Aber tatsächlich habe ich momentan das Gefühl, ich bewege mich technologisch nach hinten. Ich bin gerade gefangen in einer Zeitreise, weil wenn wir uns zum Beispiel die Entwicklung des
Phones angucken, des Mobilphones,
dann sehen wir erst ein
Feature, Telefonat, dann
kommt ein zweites Feature dazu,
Rechner, Taschenrechner, SMS,
Wapp, Kamera,
Filter,
Internetanbindung und so weiter. Und bei mir
bei meinem Handy bewege ich mich gerade rückwärts. Ich verliere jede Woche ein Feature. Als erstes habe ich verloren die Kamera, die nach vorne zeigt. Wie ist das passiert? Du siehst es hier, es ist kaputt. Ah ja. Es ist kaputt, einfach die Linse ist zerbrochen, Loch dritt, zerborsten, keine Ahnung wie. Sieht aus wie so ein kleiner Hammer, den man so kennt aus diesem Bus. So ein S-Badenhammer hat die kaputt gemacht. Das heißt, ich konnte nur noch Selfies machen. Auch wenn ich andere Leute fotografieren wollte, musste ich es mit der Selfie-Kamera machen, was diese Leute sehr irritiert. Das heißt, alle Bilder, die ich ... Was auch die Notre-Dame sehr irritiert hat, dass du quasi mit der Selfie-Cam auf Notre-Dame und dann Urlaubsfotos machst. Das heißt, die meisten Bilder von anderen Leuten haben einen sehr irritierten Gesichtsausdruck. Wenn man jemandem sagt, ich mache ein Foto von dir, rechnet man nicht, die Person rechnet nicht damit, dass sie sich gerade selber im Display sieht und ist dann so ein, hä? Könnte aber ein spannendes Kunstprojekt werden. Finde ich schön. Ja, finde ich schön. Wären nicht alle Bilder unscharf, könnte das ein sehr interessanter Instagram-Account sein. Und somit war die Frontkamera weg. Mittlerweile ist jetzt auch die Selfie-Kamera. Hat sich jetzt auch verabschiedet, ist auch raus, wahrscheinlich wegen Überbelastung.
Und jetzt war ich in Hamburg am Bahnhof und ich wollte mir so ein Carsharing-Auto suchen und vor dem Auto war eine ziemlich grosse Pfütze und ich dachte mir, die ist nicht so tief, mit der komme ich klar. Es war eine klassische Selbstüberhöhung, Selbstüberschätzung, ich wollte die Pfütze beeindrucken, ich wollte alle um mich herum beeindrucken, ich dachte, nein, ich habe dicke Sohlen, ich habe heute meine dicksohligen Schuhe an, überhaupt kein Problem, steige also direkt in die Mitte der Pfütze rein, Meine Füsse komplett unter Wasser sofort, Schuhe komplett nass, ich steige ins Auto ein, setze mich hin, in dem Moment, in dem ich sitze, fällt mein Handy aus der linken Hosentasche raus, fällt direkt in die Pfütze rein. Also diese scheisse Pfütze hat mich einfach doppelt erwischt, einfach zwei zu null für die Pfütze, die hat mich einfach vernichtet. Pfütze. So nach drei Minuten Spielzeit steht schon zwei zu null für die Pfütze. Ich hebe also mein Handy raus, denke mir, okay, fuck, ist kaputt, ging ja noch einigermaßen, aber die Taschenlampe ist jetzt auch raus. Durch diesen Wasserschaden hat es einfach die Taschenlampe erwischt. Und ich weiß nicht, was das System ist. Ehrlich gesagt ist es auch kein Problem mehr. Also wenn Kamera weg ist, finde ich, ist eine Taschenlampe auch so ein Tropfen auf den heissen Stein. Absolut, ja, absolut. Deswegen, ich habe jetzt mein weiterer Verlust ist jetzt die Taschenlampe. Ich bewege mich also immer weiter zurück ins Jahr 1996, wo man irgendwann nur noch einen Brocken hat, mit dem man telefonieren kann. So einen richtig grossen Knochen. Ja, so ein schöner Knochen, so ein schlichtiger Nokia-Knochen. Und ich bewege mich langsam aber sicher darauf zurück. Und es ist interessant, weil es hat ja sowas von Minimalismus, sowas von Diogenes, der sagt, ich brauche das alles nicht, wie wenig brauche ich, um zu leben? Genau. Und das ist so ein bisschen so eine erzwungene Minimalismus-Weg, den ich jetzt gerade eingeschlagen habe. Ein bisschen wie das Dumpfone, was es gibt. Gab es lange mal auf Kickstarter ein Projekt, was sehr beliebt war, ich glaube eines der beliebsten Projekte auch, ein Handy, was keine Social Media Fähigkeiten hat oder sowas, sondern einfach quasi moderne SMS abschicken kann und telefonieren kann. Aber du hast keine Apps, du hast kein Social Media Kram, du hast nichts, was dich ablenkt. Und das wurde Dumbphone getauft, as opposed to Smartphone, und ein Kollege von mir hat das dann bestellt,
der ist auch so ein Indiegogo-Kickstarter-Aficionado und hat das dann bestellt,
und es ist bis heute nicht angekommen.
Und es war vor vier Jahren oder so,
es hat leider keine GPS-Funktion,
es findet dich leider nicht. Es ist so dumm, dieses Handy,
es hat den Weg nicht zu ihm geschafft,
und in letzter Konsequenz fand ich das auch irgendwie richtig.
Ja, absolut. Zu sagen,
ja, du hast es jetzt nicht bekommen,
und ist nicht das, was du wolltest,
weniger zu können. Genau, vielleicht ist das beste
Es ist ein, das wir gar nicht hast. Richtig. Vielleicht ist das die Botschaft. Vielleicht ist das beste für dich, einfach kein Handy zu haben. Ja. Irgendwann werde ich da sein. Irgendwann wird es einfach nicht mehr funktionieren. Ich habe es einfach nur noch als Hosentaschen. Aber du kannst ja jetzt gar keine QR-Code scannen, wenn du auf einen Roller steigst oder sowas. Kann ich gar nichts mehr tun. Weil ich es in Paris nicht verstanden habe, das ist irgendwie neu, dass man, wenn man da einen Roller abstellen will, erstmal gibt es so einen Roller, Parkzonen, könnt ihr bei Instagram, habe ich fotografiert, was weird aussieht. Das sind riesige Parkzonen, dann knallen alle ihre Roller hin und dann kannst du es nur da abstellen. dann, bevor du es wirklich entsperren kannst und dann quasi auch nicht mehr weiter zahlt, musst du die Häuser um dich herum scannen. Zumindest bei den Tierrollern ist das so. Du musst dein Handy in die Luft strecken und dann wirklich einfach mit der Kamera die Häuserfronten scannen. Und irgendwie kommen die damit durch, weil man denkt, ah okay, die wollen gucken,
ob man wirklich in der Parkzone ist, unabhängig vom GPS. Aber es ist ja,
wenn man nochmal darüber nachdenkt, völliger Unsinn,
weil GPS funktioniert ja auch
wahrscheinlich einigermaßen gut.
Heißt, was machen die da gerade? Bauen die da,
was plant Tier?
Tier ist für mich mittlerweile so ein, ich stelle mir so ein großes
Hochhaus, so ein schwarzes
Wayne-Enterprise-artiges Hochhaus, stelle ich mir vor, wo oben immer so hell erleuchtet irgendwie so ein Penthouse ist, wo so ein weirder Chef, Herr Thier, Mr Thier.
Und es ist so ein riesiges, hoher, riesiger Komplex, und man fragt, was macht ihr? Ja, diese Roller.
Roller.
Auf 200 Stecken.
Ciao, tschüss.
Diese Roller, aber warum brauchen sie dafür so viel Platz?
Securities.
Wir machen ja die Roller. Stockwerk 1 bis Stockwerk 280 sind diese Roller, diese Mietroller. Das ist alles für die, da braucht man viele Daten. Warum muss ich denn die Häuser scannen? Warum muss ich die Häuser scannen? Damit wir wissen, wo sie sind, damit sie nicht das GPS ... Warum haben Sie da eine Waffe an dem Halfter? Halfter? Halster. Ist das eine Waffe? Bitte? Nichts. Holster. Ich finde alleine Holster. Nee, das ist der Schiri, der beschissen hat. Nee, Holzer. Holzer. Robert Holzer. Holzer? Weiß ich nicht mehr. Holster oder Halfter? Nee, eine Sache ist, was weiß ich, Pferde-related und die andere Sache ist Waffen-related. Ich weiß nicht, was was ist. Halfter ist meine ich für Pferde. Ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung. Da müssten wir jetzt die Cowboys fragen, wie das heißt, wo man den Revolver reinsteckt. Aber für mich ist das, was macht hier damit? Ich glaube, dass hier so eine Google Maps-artige Streetview-Ide verfolgt. Ja, aber warum dann nur von ein paar Orten in der Stadt? Das bringt ja auch nicht so viel, oder? Wenn du dich an den Orten richtig gut ausfällst. Das sind schon viele Orte. Ich verstehe nicht. Also man muss das scannen. Wenn jetzt jemand weiß, würde das interessieren. Vielleicht ist es dann so ein Beweis, dass du da tatsächlich warst. Weil wenn du dann den Roller kaputt machst, dann können die sagen, du warst doch da. Wir haben hier das Bildmaterial, du hast doch das gefilmt oder nicht. Wohingegen GPS-Daten könnte man sagen, nee, da hat eine Taube mein Handy geklaut. Wohingegen so kann es sagen, eine Taube hat einmal alle Gebäude um sie herum gefilmt. Ja, das soll ich glauben, dass eine französische Pariser Stadttaube in der Lage war, einmal rundherum die Umgebung zu finden. Sie wissen gar nicht, wie weit diese Pariser Stadttauben sind. Die haben schon alles gesehen, die haben schon alles erlebt, die sind mittlerweile so advanced und kulturell auch interessiert, die kriegen das hin. Ihr Anwalt hat das letzte Wort. Worst bird. It's the worst bird. It's the worst bird. Leider auch schon 20 Jahre in Folge, Worst Bird of the Year, die Taube. Taube. Einfach immer gewesen und wird es immer sein, hoffentlich. Ich habe ein Spiel Dortmund gegen Bayern reingesappt. Spannend. Und im Dortmunder Stadion waren einfach und die ganze Zeit waren auf dem Feld so zehn Tauben, die sehr verwirrt waren, was da passiert. Hat einer eine rote Karte bekommen oder was? Einer eine rote Karte bekommen. Fussballergeg! Yes! Sehr gut. Die meisten standen die ganze Zeit im Abseits. Aber dann standen da diese Tauben und die waren immer verwirrt, was da gerade passiert um sie herum. Und weil die konnten dann nirgendwo hinlanden. Warum schiesst der nicht? Die man so verwirrt, wie schlecht Dortmund gespielt hat.
Geht doch ab, Mensch!
Aber wie nervig, weil du hast halt 80.000 Fans um dich herum.
Dann auf diesem Feld wirst du immer von A nach B getrieben,
weil rot- beziehungsweise gelbleibige Männer auf dich zulaufen
und einen Ball vor sich hertreten.
Für die Tauben noch ein denkbar komisches Ereignis.
Ja, total.
Vor allem dieses Stadion trotzt ja voruntergefallenen Pommes, nehme ich mal an. Das ist ja eigentlich ein Eldorado für Tauben. Also sie lieben es aber hassen es auch. Ja, sie sind halt nur einfach an dem Auge des Orkans, wo halt gerade keine Pommes liegen oder wenig. Sie werden angeschrien von so 80.000 Fans und so. Angepfiffen, faul, kriegen dieses Spray ab irgendwie. Schwierig. Ich dachte, was denkt diese Taube, was jetzt hier los ist? Aber das stimmt schon, wenn sich Tauben mal in einem Stadion eingenistet haben, die kriegst es ja nicht mehr raus. Oder so viel Pommes und Leberkäse, der da rumliegt und irgendwie Zuckerwatte. Ich war noch nie in einem Stadion, ich habe keine Ahnung. Zuckerwatte, ja. Aber gebrannte Mandeln oder ich weiß nicht, Club-Sandwiches, ich weiß nicht, was man da verzerrt. Aber komisch nur, wie spezifisch die Snacks auf die jeweiligen Ereignisse zugeschnitten sind. Kino kann man keine Pommes kaufen. Man kann im Kino keine Pommes kaufen. Wohingegen im Stadion kann man keine Popcorn kaufen, oder? Nee. Was kauft man da? Wir waren ja nur in einem Baseballspiel, da konntest du eine Menge kaufen. Ja, das ist auch Amerika. Aber das sei einfach USA, ja. Im Stadion kannst du Currywurst kaufen, kannst du Pommes kaufen und das war's. Keine Hotdogs. Will ich mir sicher aus dem Fenster lehnen. Wahrscheinlich Hotdogs, Bratwurst, Bratwurst, Krisse. Na gut. Aber sowas. Und damit beschränkt es sich eigentlich auch da drauf. Aber es sind alles keine Gerichte, die du beim Kino kaufen kannst. Aber kann man da nicht was Neues etablieren? Ist der Geruch vielleicht ein Problem, aber Popcorn riecht auch doll. Ja, vielleicht kann man da was Neues etablieren. Vielleicht mal irgendwie so ein Becher Wackelpudding oder so. Und Popcorn ist auch ein Scheiß, eigentlich kontraintuitiv, für Filme. Weil es laut ist. Ja, für Schinders Liste wurde es verboten, weil es respektlos ist. Zu knabbern wäre ein Schinders Liste. Aber alle anderen Filme sind scheißegal. Arrival knabbert da gern durch. Mir egal.
Ist völlig egal. Völlig egal. Ich hätte auch, glaube ich, so eine Regel. Wenn ich einen Film rausbringen würde, der im Kino wäre, hätte ich auch so gesagt. Nee, Popcorn ist verboten. Ich glaube, wenn ich richtig viel Geld hätte, würde ich einerseits eine Wohnung dir zur Verfügung stellen ohne Dach, andererseits ein Projekt das schlimmste Kino der Welt. Wirklich ein Kino, das wirklich das schlimmste Kino der Welt ist, Wo ausschliesslich Suppen verkauft werden und ausschliesslich alle so ganz quietschige Strohalme haben. Der Boden ist mit so einem so leicht angeklebt, so einmal mit einem Prittstift komplett über den Boden. Ja, auch die Suppe ist immer so grosse Portionen, die dafür gedesignt sind, dass du nicht kannst, die aufschaffst. Und dann, was jeder kennt, dieses, man stellt's nach vor sich hin im Dunkeln, und wenn man nicht selber das umtritt, tritt jemand, der aufs Klo geht um. Und alle müssen aufs Klo, weil alle einen halben Liter Suppe in sich aufgenommen haben, und die Gänge sind so superschmal, dass man sich da so vorbeischiebt, dass man gegen diese Suppen alle umkippt. Und alle zehn Minuten kommt jemand mit einem riesen Kessel Suppe rein und einem Löffel und sagt will noch Suppe refill und geht einmal durch alle rein mit seinem riesigen... Ob du willst oder nicht, der ballert dir noch ultra heiß, super heiß, der Topf ist riesig, der schiebt sich da durch die Reihen, du kriegst einen riesigen heißen Topf an den Kopf und alle zehn Minuten halt einfach wird das Licht angemacht, der Film läuft weiter, Licht wird angemacht aus Sicherheitsgründen und dann wird nochmal Suppen-Refill gemacht. Ich dachte gerade, vielleicht ist es sogar noch nerviger, um das Ereignis nicht enden zu lassen, dass der Film immer angehalten wird bei jedem Suppen-Refill, damit das Ergebnis noch länger bleibt. Ja, und dann mal gucken, wie lange dauert es, bis eine Woche lang kein einziger Besucher in dem Kino war. Wie lange dauert es wirklich, bis niemand mehr dahingeht? Ist es teuer oder billig? Billig, die Filme sind super, die Audioqualität ist toll, die Leinwand ist super, die Sitze sind sehr weich. Es gibt halt nur dieses Scheiss-Suppen-Problem und die Leute schreiben auch, sie kritiken immer, tolles Kino, nette Mitarbeiter, aber halt diese konstante Suppenpräsenz, ich hab dem gesagt, wir wollen keine Suppe mehr, der hat uns die in den Becher geballert mit einer Wucht, also dieses glühend heiße Suppen-Ungetüm jedes Mal. Ich find auch gut, wenn das so ein sehr intensiver Geruch wäre, so Curry. Oder so eine Zwiebel, ja genau. So Zwiebel-Curry. Und irgendwann hassen alle diesen Suppenmann, der alle zehn Minuten reinkommt und der wird ausgebucht und mit Suppe beworfen und mit Popcorn beworfen, aber er kommt trotzdem alle zehn Minuten einmal durch alle Reihen durch und alle haben auch am Ende so eine riesen Suppenflecken auf ihren Shirts. Super geil. Auch alles in 3D, immer alle 3D-Filme, damit man noch weniger Kontrolle hat auf dem... Weniger versteht, wo man ist. Die Gerüche desorientieren einen komplett. Der Gaumen ist bis zur Unkenntlichkeit verbrannt, weil wenn man dann doch mal versucht, was zu essen, ist einfach viel zu heiß. Wird auch nicht kühler. Aber es gibt Geruchskino, Geruchs, und weil ich musste damals immer schmunzeln, herrlich lachend über den Gag, aber es war auch kein Geruchsfernsehen, diesen Spruch, den man auch in Kochsendungen sehr oft gesehen hat, aber zum Glück ist es kein Geruchsfernsehen. Das gibt es ja, was ich nicht wusste, dass es das gibt, aber es gibt es im Europapark. Oh Gott, ja in deiner Zauberwelt gibt's alles. In meiner Fantasywelt, wo ich der Protagonist bin und ich bin der Star. Da gibt's jedenfalls, ähm, ja, gab's sowas. Und nachdem, warum macht man sich überall? Das ist doch die konsequente Weiterentwicklung von diesen drei, vier D-Wackel-D-Übersesseln, auf denen wir waren. Du hast dir dann so einen Schlauch in die Nase gesteckt, oder wie funktioniert das dann?
Nee, ich war übrigens der Einzige, der das gemerkt hat, weil ich so eine gute Nase habe, war ich der Einzige von allen, gut, wir hatten auch
alle Masken auf, aber trotz Maske habe ich gemerkt,
oh, hier kommt es auch, weil man ist über so einen
Kieferwald geflogen, dann war so Nadelbaumgeruch.
Und das ist fantastisch,
es gibt es offensichtlich, und das verstehe ich
nicht, warum man das nicht im Kino macht, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber wie kriegst du den vorhergehenden Geruch wieder raus?
Der verfliegt. Wie verfliegt? Wie, ich habe so ein gutes Beispiel, Ich bin vor dem, was ich nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, wie ich es nicht mehr so viel, warum man das nicht im Kino macht, ehrlich gesagt. Aber wie kriegst du den vorhergehenden Geruch wieder raus? Der verfliegt. Wie verfliegt? Wie, ich habe so ein gutes Beispiel, so ein Furz. Der ist ja nicht konstant dann im Raum. Gerüche verfliegen ja schnell. Was heißt verfliegen? Wo fliegen die hin? Naja, in jedem Raum hast du ja Luftbewegungen drin. Hier jetzt, in diesem Raum ist das Gegenteil von Luftbewegungen. Weiter. Weil kleiner Schmetterling kann Orkanen verursachen in der anderen Ecke des Raumes. Weiter. Und dann, wenn dein Fernseher Geruch ausschüttet, dann ist er relativ schnell verflogen. Also verteilt. Aber ist dann der Raum nicht irgendwann voll mit Gerüchen? Ich glaube ja, dass wenn man mal unter die Decke fliegt, deswegen bin ich ja generell gegen Dächer, aber ich glaube, da hängen ganz viele Gerüche. Ja, das kannst du am besten bewerten. Ich meine, du bist sehr groß. Ich bin 18 Meter gross. Du bist immer zwei Geruchsebenen über allen anderen. Ja. Also ich bin der Meinung, man sollte das mal einfach ausprobieren. Gibt es da einfach so einen Samsung-Fernseher oder sowas? Gibt es da einen, der schöne Gerüche kann? Wir können natürlich auch Projekt Geruchspodcast vorantreiben, dass wir einfach sagen, das Podcast-Ufe wird der erste Geruchspodcast. Wir haben heute gesprochen über Billardtische, Regen, Suppe, diese Kreide, Suppe, du hast von Weinen gesprochen, wir haben Pfirsich, das sind tolle Gerüche, die kann man alle mit... Wir müssen so eine Kerze rausbringen, die genau eine Stunde lang brennt und die wir so schichten, dass sie genau die passenden Gerüche hat. Also zu jeder Folge gibt es eine Kerze und die zündet man an, wenn man mit der Folge beginnt und dann ist die genau so getaktet wie die Themen, über die wir sprechen und dann immer der passende Geruch, das ist gar keine dumme Idee eigentlich. Nee, ist gar keine dumme Idee. Das ist wirklich keine dumme Idee. Wie heißt die Kerze? Das Podcast-UFO. Haltet die Augen auf im Shop und schaut mal, dass ihr vielleicht ein paar Weihnachtsgeschenke noch offen haltet, denn das kommt, glaube ich, übermorgen auf dem Markt. Hier kommen Ideen, wir ballern Ideen raus und ihr könnt gucken im Shop, was da noch kommt für geile Weihnachtsgeschenke Ideen. Schaut mal vorbei, schaut auch mal auf Patreon vorbei, ob der Ufo Club was für euch ist.
Falls ihr keinen Bock mehr auf Werbungen habt in der Folge, da könnt ihr alle Folgen werbefrei hören.
Schaut mal vorbei, ansonsten wünschen wir euch eine schöne Woche.
Haut rein.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
Und wir eben ab.
It's a voice by production.